hey I'm Dan Perrault and these are 10
reasons to see Batman vs Superman number
10 the expanding DC Universe Man of
Steel was the first entry in the DC
Cinematic Universe but Batman vs
Superman will give us a much bigger
glimpse of it will learn about Batman's
past with the Joker will get plenty of
teases to the Justice League and we get
the first ever live-action film
appearance of Wonder Woman she would do
hero number 9 Lex Luthor
there's a lot of differences between the
traditional Lex Luthor and the version
that Jesse Eisenberg is playing like
hair but Eisenberg seems to have that
manipulative Lex Luthor thing down which
makes sense because he kind of stole
Facebook I believe I deserve some
recognition number 8 Zack Snyder action
he knows how to portray ultra powerful
characters like Superman and Wonder
Woman and Batman's bone-crushing fights
looked like they came straight out of an
Arkham video game number 7 the history
of Batman vs Superman there is a long
history of Batman and Superman moments
for this movie to draw from like when
Batman fought Superman in the new 52 and
when Lex Luthor brainwashed Superman to
take on Batman in the animated series
hopefully they won't use the story of
their first ever meet up in the comics
where they accidentally met as roommates
on a cruise ship but I know they'll
definitely be using a lot of number 6
The Dark Knight Returns some argue it's
the greatest graphic novel of all time
and we already know that Batman vs
Superman is using some major plot points
from it like the comic Affleck's Batman
is retired and aging in Phillies
inspired to make an epic comeback and it
also seems like batfleck is wearing that
awesome Dark Knight Returns armored bat
suit number 5 David Goyer lawyer was a
writer for each film on the Dark Knight
trilogy not to mention the Blade trilogy
and Man of Steel number four the
director's cut is are rated many people
thought Deadpool would start a trend of
r-rated superhero flicks and it's
already happening with this one the
blu-ray will include an r-rated
director's cut and my parents let me
watch it I'll be so excited
number three the bat vehicles the new
Batmobile is awesome it combines the
power of the tumbler with the sleek
style of the classic Batmobiles and
we're also getting a new bat jet or
batwing or bat plane whatever it is is
cool
number two Hans Zimmer he composed some
of the greatest superhero
in history with the Dark Knight trilogy
now he's teaming up with junkie XL who
also composed the Deadpool sport and
finally number one the final fight it
may be titled Batman vs Superman but the
third trailer shows us it'll be a much
bigger match than that it appears as
though Batman Superman and Wonder Woman
will join forces to take on doomsday one
of the most powerful characters in the
DC Universe and could Aquaman the flash
or cyborg help out only time and
Internet spoilers will tell checkout
Batman vs Superman in theaters March
25th